inflammation is a local immune response
to tissue injury or
infection experienced as heat redness
edema pain and loss of
function immediately after injury
inflammation begins with brief Vaso
constriction of the local blood vessels
to reduce blood loss and formation of a
clot to stop the
bleeding then stimulated by cell injury
and death local cells release vasoactive
chemicals such as prostaglandins and
histamine to dilate local blood vessels
leading to increased blood flow to the
area these chemicals also cause
endothelial cells in small blood vessels
to contract opening spaces between
them this increased capillary
permeability allows fluids and proteins
to pass from the blood into the
tissue next during a multi-stage process
called
chemotaxis circulating immune cells
neutrophils move out of the blood
vessels to the site of injury and
Destroy pathogens and damage
cells chemotaxis begins when cells at
the injury site release messenger
molecules called
chemoattractants which cause local
endothelial cells and circulating
neutrophils to stick together next in a
process called
diapedesis neutrophils squeeze through
the endothelial
gaps the neutrophils migrate to the
injury site by following a chemotactic
gradient upon arrival the neutrophils
encounter bacteria engulf them and
digest them in a process called
phagocytosis after destruction of the
bacteria and removal of cellular waste
tissue repair begins when locally
produced growth factors cause local
fibroblasts to begin dividing rapidly
and secreting large quantities of
collagen to reinforce the
wound anti-inflammatory drugs inhibit
inflammation by blocking production of
inflammatory
chemicals the most common drugs for
inflammation are not non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs or
Ides such as aspirin and
ibuprofen they contain an enzyme called
cyclooxygenase or Cox that inhibits the
production of
progins and several other inflammatory
chemicals thus reducing vasod
dilation edema and pain associ assciated
with
inflammation